AINSLEY: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, JANICE.
SPEAKING OF THE WEATHER.
IT WAS 11 DEGREES WHERE THIS
COLUMBIA MOTHER AND DAUGHTER
FOUND DEAD IN THE DESSERT OF
ARIZONA AFTER CROSSING THE
BORDER TO SEEK ASYLUM.
HER NAME WAS CLAUDIA MARCELLA
PIN I CAN’T.
AND SHE SHARED A PHOTO OF HER
YOUNG DAUGHTER CARRYING HER
YOUNG DAUGHTER 2-YEAR-OLD
THROUGH THE DESSERT AND HOURS
LATER CLAUDIA AND 10-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER DIED FROM HEAT
EXPOSURE.
CLAWED YAPS HUSBAND WHO LIVES
DOWN IN FLORIDA TOLD HER TO GO
BACK.
SHE SAID SHE WAS ALREADY THERE
THEN MY DAUGHTER SAID NO, DAD, I
REALLY WANT TO SEE YOU.
THEY ONLY HAD 25% BATTERY LEFT
ON THEIR PHONE.
STEVE: CLAUDIA MADE A FRANTIC
CALL TO 911 FOR HELP.
BUT HER PHONE DIED BEFORE SHE
COULD SEND THE LOCATION.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE OUT
THERE WHEN IT’S HOT LIKE THAT.
>> THIS STORY HURTS.
ANY BORDER PATROL AGENT THAT HAS
EVER HAD TO DEAL WITH DEATH, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WITHOUT PROPER
POLICY AND PROGRAMS IN PLACE WE
CAN’T JUST REACH THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN TIME TO KNOW THIS
TRAGEDY WAS PREVENTABLE, TO KNOW
THAT HAD WE HAD THE PROPER
RESOURCES IN THE AREA AND
AVAILABLE WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SAVE THESE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE HAD AGENTS THAT HAVE
DIED, PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE TO GO IN TO SAVE THESE
PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
TO KNOW THIS WAS PREVENTABLE,
REALLY UPSETS US AND IT HURTS
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE HAD TO SEE
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AINSLEY: THE PRESIDENT IS
SECURING TAJIKISTAN BORDERS TO
PROTECT FOLKS FROM THE TALIBAN.
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AGENTS SAY
THIS IS A SLAP IN THE FACE.
HE WILL SECURE THAT BORDER BUT
NOT OURS.
THEY SAY IT’S HEARTENING TO SAY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FINALLY
GETTING SERIOUS ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY.
IT’S TOO BAD IT’S IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
THEY SAY THIS IS A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO THE U.S.
BIDEN HAS ALREADY DESTROYED
AFGHANISTAN.
SO THE BORDERS DON’T NEED TO BE
OPEN.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION, BRANDON?
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE COMPLETE AND TOTAL CHAOS
ON OUR SOUTHWEST BORDER.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO IS COME IN.
WE DON’T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
COME FRFMENT WE DON’T KNOW WHAT
THEIR INTENTIONS ARE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YET, IS HE WILLING TO GO AND
SECURE A BORDER OF ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
HIS RESPONSIBILITY IS TO HIS
CITIZENS, TO ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY TO EVERYBODY THAT’S
CURRENTLY HERE.
THAT’S WHERE HIS RESPONSIBILITY
IS.
YET, IS HE FAILING IN THAT AND
HE IS FAILING MISERABLY.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE THREAT THAT
WE FACE ON A DAILY BASIS, AND
THE PROTECTION OF CITIZENS OF
THIS COUNTRY, WHERE IS HE?
AND IS HE NOWHERE TO BE FOUND
AND, YES, IT IS VERY IRONIC THAT
HE IS WILLING TO GO AND SECURE
THE BORDER OF ANOTHER COUNTRY
BUT HE IS NOT WILLING TO SECURE
OUR OWN BORDERS FOR OUR OWN
CITIZENS.
STEVE: IT IS FRUSTRATING FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE.
BRANDON, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR